this is Sky News breakfast live from
Downing Street home to Liz truss for
just a few more days after six turbulent
weeks as prime minister but who will
move in next and is Boris Johnson really
kicking the sand off his sandals in the
Caribbean ready for a new run at the top
job we'll hear from his former
right-hand man will Walden from senior
Tori MP's Crispin blunt and Sir
Christopher chope Labor's Rachel Reeves
and the live Den Leader Ed Davey it's
Friday the 21st of October
the race is on that Liz truss's
departure means there'll be a new prime
minister exactly a week today at the
latest
Out of the Shadows Boris Johnson is
expected to return early from his
Caribbean holiday with supporters
calling for a comeback
he's a known winner and that's certainly
who I'm putting my name against because
I want us to win the next election
I could just urge colleagues who may be
thinking of throwing their hat into the
ring just take stop
put their own put the country before
their own personal ambition
it's threatening to be a crowded field
to replace Britain's shortest serving
prime minister but there's only room for
three when the counting starts
opposition parties call for an end to
the upheaval and demand a general
election
[Music]
also ahead grid logs the damning report
showing patients unable to leave
hospital and a Health and Care System
seizing up
foreign
a very good morning from Downing Street
the morning after a dramatic day
culminating in Liz truss's resignation
here yesterday afternoon after six
turbulent weeks the race to be the next
prime minister is already shaping up to
be remarkable Boris Johnson is said to
be sounding out his supporters to see if
he's got enough votes to beat Rishi
sunak the man who quit as his Chancellor
and far from healing the party Rifts
some back benches are threatening to
resign their seats if Mr Johnson makes a
comeback
so let's take a look then at those who
are in contention well currently Rishi
sunak is the bookmaker's favorite to
take over and also has the highest
number of MPS publicly backing him 33
have come out in support so far
former prime minister Boris Johnson
follows closely behind in mp support
with 27. and in third is the commons
leader Penny Morden 12 MPS have said
that they'll back her then the defense
secretary Ben Wallace
then the trade secretary kemi badnock
could also be in the running along with
suela Braverman who resigned just days
ago as Home Secretary
Amanda acas has our first report
after Liz trusses kilometers 44 days in
power the race is on to find her
replacement the party have vowed to
choose the new occupant of 10 Downing
Street by Friday in a bid to rebuild
after the shortest term of any British
prime minister in history
I recognize though given the situation I
cannot deliver the Mandate on which I
was elected by the conservative party
I have therefore spoken to his majesty
the king to notify him that I am
resigning as leader of the conservative
party
supporters of Rishi sunak and Penny
mordant are already out on maneuvers in
these times when we're facing now we've
got horrific problems in the global
financial markets and we need somebody
who's got the experience to deliver real
stability over the next few years hope
that she does stand out back to her back
in the summer when there was a
leadership election after Boris had
resigned and I and I hope she put puts
herself um forward again I'll certainly
enthusiastically back out but in an
extraordinary twist some MPS are hoping
Liz truss's downfall could pave a way
back for the former prime minister Boris
Johnson he's said to be cutting short
his Caribbean holiday to sound out his
supporters
he's a known winner and that's certainly
who I'll be putting my name against
because I want us to win the next
election and it's time for it's time for
some stability and some unity and I
think in order to achieve that we need
to put in place I believe the person who
has the Mandate of the British people
others in the party are calling for
restraint I would just urge colleagues
who may be thinking of throwing their
hat into the ring just take stop
put their own put the country before
their own personal ambition and let's
try and get on and you know dig us out
of the hole we've that we've actually
put the country into and also ourselves
into as well
labor wants another general election
so you've got this real Choice utter
chaos with the conservatives or
stability under a labor government so
the risk is not a general election the
risk is carrying on with this utter
chaos
for voters living in Liz truss's Norfolk
constituency it's been exhausting
it's like a children's playground really
unbelievable I think they're
conservative party are
will be destroying themselves
they are slowly destroying themselves
they've really got to you know sort it
out
last night the ultimate humiliation the
lettuce which The Daily Star bet would
Outlast Liz truss's Premiership beamed
onto the walls of parliament whoever
wins the contest to succeed her has an
uphill struggle ahead Amanda a cast Sky
News
well this trust entered number 10 after
a leadership campaign that lasted eight
weeks she finally became prime minister
after 81 000 conservative party members
voted for her this time around that
process will last just one week and it
could be over even sooner than that well
nominations are open now and they're
going to close at 2PM on Monday
candidates must secure 100 nominations
from MPS to get through if only one
Contender reaches that Mark they'll be
elected prime minister on Monday
while assuming at least two make it
through MPS will vote between 3 30 and 5
30 on Monday if there are three the
person with the fewest votes will be
eliminated well the remaining two
candidates will then face televised
hustings
and the final choice will be made by
conservative party members in an online
vote which closes at 11AM next Friday
the 28th of October and the result will
then be announced by that evening at the
latest
well our political correspondent repel
is here with me this morning morning to
you rob an incredible day in politics
once again yesterday and we find
ourselves in this extraordinary position
of facing another leadership battle for
the top of the Tory party in the Prime
Minister yeah incredible week it was
this time last week that quasi quateng
was still Chancellor was flying back
from Washington where he'd just given an
interview assuring everyone that both he
and the Prime Minister would still be
imposed in a month's time a week on and
they are both gone let's trust the
shortest serving prime minister ever
probably will go down as one of the
least successful Prime Ministers ever as
well really having the indignity of
watching all of her policies that she
set out over the summer being Stripped
Away in the final days of her
Premiership in terms of what happens now
as you say we are obviously into another
race to find another prime minister and
conservative leader but the crucial
difference in this race is how short it
is and crucially that they need a
hundred nominations to get onto that
ballot initially now that was 20 in the
last leadership race and what that means
is there will be far fewer people who
realistically make it to the MP's ballot
and it may well be that it doesn't even
make it to a ballot or a member's ballot
as well and what it essentially means is
that there are probably only three
people really In Contention and those
names are probably Rishi sunak Penny
mordant and Boris Johnson well yes some
people might be surprised that his name
is is being put forward potentially How
likely is a comeback by the former prime
minister I'm told by one of his friends
this morning that it's likely that he's
up for it now despite the common sitting
Boris Johnson is on holiday in the
Caribbean he is reportedly flying back
early from that he has already had MPS
coming out in sports for him he's got
around 30 I think publicly declared by
our account maybe slightly under now the
argument they make is that he has the
Mandate that he won the 2019 election
and he'll be able to win another
election you heard Nadine dory's in the
piece there say saying that what the
country needs is unity and stability and
that Boris Johnson can provide that
there is an Almighty question mark over
whether he can really provide unity and
stability there remember it was three or
four months ago that dozens of his own
ministers were resigning saying he was
unfit to govern he's facing an
investigation by a committee of MPS into
potentially misleading Parliament there
are other investigations into close
allies of him that are going on that
have potential to derail as well
backbenchers say that they will
potentially walk out of the party or
Trigger by-elections or even defect to
labor if he comes back as prime minister
so it's very hard to say that he is a
unifier a Unity candidate here but I
think that speaks to the broader point
that can anyone unify this party at the
moment opposition parties say no and
that's why they say it should be a
general election well yes but what are
the chances of that I think very low
because it would be turkey's voting for
Christmas situation I think and given
one doesn't have to come for two years
and there's not a lot of opposition
parties can do to forces Tori MPS know
that given the polls how they are at the
moment they're probably better off
hanging on for a couple couple of years
and hoping things get better rather than
the near certainty of them losing many
of their seats if there was to be a boat
around the corner so complications
around Boris Johnson complications also
around Rishi sunac because there are
some in the party very loyal to Boris
Johnson who feel that Rishi sunak was
disloyal to him and then Penny mordant
of course was in the cabinet that
approved that mini budget which proved
to have such a huge impact on on the
economy and people's mortgages yeah and
I think this probably speaks to the
broader point of given the rancor that
we have had not just over the last six
weeks probably over the last six months
within the conservative party are the
divisions in this party so deep now that
can any leader realistically bring them
back together behind them I think for
Rishi sunak there are still those
problems hanging over him a lot of Boris
lawyer Boris Johnson loyalists still do
feel aggrieved towards him he has the
upside though that I think he pretty
much called it right in terms of his
view on the economy and what could go
wrong if Liz just made it into number
10. interesting reports in the papers
this morning of conversations that have
been going on between Rishi sunak and
Boris Johnson to try and sort of patch
things up if you like I think that
division though on both sides is why
some people point to Penny mortens and
say look maybe she can come through the
middle as more of a unified candidate
but I think there's a big question for
penny more than over whether given that
bar is set so high at 100 people 100 MPS
needed whether she actually has the
support within the Parliamentary party
to make it to that level and you
mentioned the word Unity we talk about
stability the need for stability at a
time when a lot of people are really
worried about the cost of living crisis
is there a chance that the potential
candidates could come together and agree
amongst themselves a plan of action and
announce that on Monday I mean
potentially but you're dealing with a
lot of big egos here and a lot of people
that have wanted coveted this top job if
you like for a very long time I think
it's interesting how the conversation
has already turned you look at some of
the newspapers this morning and talk of
on the front page of the Daily Mail of a
fight for the heart of the conservative
party whereas one two days ago all the
talk was about potentially a coronation
someone coming forward and this being
lesser leadership battle and more just
them trying to sort of continue put
someone else in place you could reassure
the market keep Jeremy hunting the
treasury and potentially get the country
back on an even Keel again the challenge
for the conservative party I think over
the next week is to try to not let this
get into the sort of bloodletting that
we saw over the summer because remember
this is set against a backdrop of people
paying 100 pounds per month more on
their mortgages potentially People's
Energy bills shooting up come April when
some of that support is paired back as
well so I think people will be looking
for the focus to be on the country
rather than more Tory Psycho Drama okay
Rob is going to be a fascinating week
ahead once again how many times have I
said that on a Friday thanks very much
indeed
so let's get a view now of the
developments over the last 24 hours I'm
joined now by the conservative MP for
Ryegate Crispin blunt who's one of the
first MPS to publicly call for Liz truss
to resign and Chris been blunt very good
morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us so as I say one of the
first to call for Liz truss to go so
what your reaction now that she's gone
well all of a sudden hugely relieved uh
that we've got that issue out of the way
and we're now the process is selecting a
successor I just want to spare a thought
for uh Liz and her family it must have
been incredibly difficult
um but uh what she hasn't yet shown is
uh the self knowledge of this process of
having put ourselves forward for these
responsibilities she's made it through
the process
um and we've seen this uh rather
very difficult last six weeks but now we
can resolve that and move on
what do you say to those who today feel
that Liz truss has been let down they
might say that she's been subject to a
coup orchestrated against someone who's
just trying to do things a bit
differently
we read cons of people like Matthew
Paris uh
she simply wasn't good enough to be a
prime minister and uh the absence of the
qualities that we could see where she
was found it very difficult to
communicate effectively and the rest
um all helped uh bring this Premiership
to the conclusion that it did
so who do you think should take her
place now
my choice is now for Richie sunac
um I have wavered in the course of the
last week between Jerry huntson uh Rishi
sunak but they are the two characters
now who are plainly capable of being
prime minister uh Jeremy Hunts uh
picking up with the chancellorship and
in three days settling the markets and
the financial position of the United
Kingdom was astonishingly impressive
but as he
is not going to run then the other
candidate who is a figure who has his
qualities if not yet all of his
experience
um uh because Jeremy spent six years as
a health secretary and uh earlier uh two
or three years as culture secretary uh
Richie sunak is Head and Shoulders
ranked above the rest of us uh in terms
of his basic personal capabilities of
being prime minister and that's why he
would now be my choice he was an
outstanding Chancellor he brought in the
furlough scheme which as far as I know
was globally leading and I designed out
of his office
um this is a very very impressive man
and I think he has the seriousness of
purpose uh for the nation to listen and
to follow him in the difficult two years
we've got as we have to work through the
consequences of kovid uh the uh
consequences of standing firm the with
Ukraine which we must
um and I think he can bring not any the
conservative parties together he can
bring uh the nation together to address
the challenge that we face you think you
could bring the conservative party
together but there are a lot of people
very angry with him within the
conservative party they think he's
stabbed Boris Johnson in the back I mean
is he really someone that can pull the
party together
well we're gonna have to uh work through
the Johnson Psycho Drama I think I was a
supportive Boris right until the end
um and
I don't think we can go back there for
the next two years
uh and we need to put this contest now
uh where it sits and it's if you're like
within the it's his story contest in two
years time we're going to face the
election
and we need to face the electorate uh
with uh two years of restored sound
Administration uh sound finance and
people being confident that the
conservatives can be trusted with the
highest office Boris Johnson has the
most astonishing set of skills there are
one or two weaknesses kicking around in
that personality and they were fairly uh
brutally exposed and amazed the subject
of all the controversy that in the end
uh led to him leaving office he is
probably not the character to restore
our reputation uh for the next uh two
years because of that uh controversy
however in the future beyond the next
general election
um as far as I'm concerned the question
is entirely open
but for now we need someone who is got
the proven personal capabilities of
being a prime minister
as well uh as then delivering uh the
kind of administration which in two
years time uh the country can make a
decision on uh having seen uh the values
and qualities of the conservative party
at their best in action
so you say he's probably not the person
to come in and pull the party together
but Boris Johnson would argue he's the
only one with a real mandate he won that
landslide in in 2019 that big majority
he would say he's got a track record of
winning elections would you be
disappointed if he replaced this trust
I I would foresee that we're going to be
probably straight back in them pickle we
were in uh when he left office and I
don't therefore think that's the right
route to take uh I want to escape from
that those uh those problems and I want
to present my party and my government to
the country in the best possible way in
2024 and I say that just interested
because I will not be standing in 2024
and I think it's these two years are
really needed to uh deliver a really
good Administration lay the foundation
for getting out of the covert crisis uh
for uh leading uh Western Europe and
contributing to the rest of the world
standing shoulder to shoulder uh with
Ukraine with the very serious security
threat uh that the Russians now pose to
order uh they're released in Europe and
of course the continuing rise in China
these are the issues that have got to be
addressed and Richie sunaki is as well
placed uh to deal with those uh as uh
Boris Johnson he's I've spent enough
time on the international circuit uh for
people who have got to know him and He
will carry a proper Authority
and that is necessary over the next two
years
um beyond that let's see what happens to
the 2024 general election and for now
the labor party has got to address uh
the fact that their program was as thin
as Liz truss from Causey Crossings in
terms of detail and that didn't Survive
by contact with the markets and reality
and this is an opportunity for them uh
to get their uh appeal to the
electorates and the basis on which their
gains of government in 2024 they will
start as all-time favorite uh okay
with with enough detail then to be for
them to be uh ready for office in 2024.
this this process will do favors for uh
for both sides
okay Crispin blunt we appreciate your
time this morning thanks very much
indeed for giving us your views on the
steps ahead thank you
so let's take a look then at what the
morning papers have been making of it
all and the Daily Telegraph has Boris
Johnson touting his credentials as the
next leader saying he claims that he
could save the party from election
Wipeout the times also leads with rumors
of a possible Johnson return
while the express dares to dream asking
he couldn't could he
the daily mails has a contest between Mr
Johnson and his former Chancellor Richie
sunak is a fight for the soul of the
Tories
the guardian describes the events of
yesterday as The Bitter End
the Metro is utterly scathing calling
this trust the worst PM we've ever had
The Mirror Has one simple demand general
election now
all the front pages as you might imagine
preoccupied with what's going on here in
Downing Street I do say by this is still
to come here on the show I'm going to
get the reaction from Neighbors Charlie
Chancellor Rachel Reeves
we'll also take a look at the polls and
see who they suggest will be the third
prime minister in two months
and Kurt Boris Johnson make a comeback
will speak to his former press secretary
will Walton
now the chaos in Westminster isn't
helping small businesses battling the
cost of living against the backdrop of
instability in the markets and I believe
there's some more bad news for the
economy with the latest retail sales
figures worse than expected so let's get
some more detail on that joining me now
is guys business correspondent Adele
Robinson so Adele give us the details
then how bad is it
well as you've just said there it's
worse than expected retail sales are
down by 1.4 percent
um that's worse than the initial
prediction of 0.5 percent and it
continues that downward Trend that we've
been seeing for the last couple of
months in August it was down by 1.6
which was later revised to 1.7 now it
could have been worse actually for
September but the figures have been
adjusted because of the bank holiday
that was in place for the Queen's uh
funeral but when all shops were shut of
course food sales were down particularly
by 1.8 percent and this of course all
once again points to that big theme the
cost of living crisis and of course
inflation The Usual Suspects that we've
been talking about for the last couple
of months so interest rate Rises
inflation the cost of living prices
energy bills and wrapped all around that
is the impending recession so there's a
feeling here particularly in Oxford from
the Traders we've spoken to uh of
gloominess over these figures but also
Over The Wider economic picture they the
ones that we've spoken to this week have
said that they feel like they've
overcome two significant hurdles in the
last few years one was the repercussions
and all the nuances of brexit for
businesses next it was covered when they
saw lots of locals and communities
rallying around small businesses they
thought they'd survived that and now
this the repercussions from the mini
budget but also the wider global
economic picture the question now is
what happens to the budget which is
still expected to go ahead a week on
Monday and the obr the office for Budget
responsibilities forecast which looks at
the prospects for economic growth for
the country businesses are hoping they
will still go ahead they need to go
ahead but of course what they're all
calling for is some political stability
to restore credibility and from that
they hope that they there will be some
answers that Financial stability will
follow
Adele thanks very much indeed
well let's take a look at some other
news now and the care regulator has
warned that a Workforce the size of the
population of Newcastle needs to be
recruited urgently to ease the
gridlocked Health and Care System the
Care Quality commission says it's
getting tougher and tougher to access
care because of a massive shortage of
workers our health correspondent Ashish
Joshi reports
even at 96 living with cancer and
diabetes Catherine is still fiercely
independent not too bad Rebecca but she
knows eventually she will need more
Specialist end-of-life Care in the
community I know there's no treatment
for me to to have for around my life any
longer so
we'll just accept what comes my way if
it can happen at the end of my life then
I you know don't mind up tolerates it I
know my daughters will do everything
possible for me to have a good ending
half a million people across the country
can't count on the same support they're
waiting for their care to start or to be
assessed it means just under half of all
patients waiting in hospitals to be
discharged can't leave even if they're
medically fit
the care sector has not has not always
had the attention that it deserves and
this year what we've seen is the system
his system has gridlocked and we're
seeing when that happens it means that
people people get stuck at home it means
that that people come to harm the sector
is hemorrhaging staff just as its
Workforce needs to be growing to keep up
with demand
care sector leaders say the cost of
living crisis has made Recruitment and
Retention harder than ever we know that
people are very low paid so there's a
huge concern about people leaving to
join other sectors where they can earn
more money via that Hospitality or
retail or supermarkets we are monitoring
closely your insulin without immediate
action staff shortages in the Health and
Care sector will increase pressure
across the NHS and in the community and
that could leave people like Catherine
more vulnerable this winter oh she's
Josh she's Sky News in South East London
the New York Court has dismissed a
sexual assault lawsuit against Kevin
Spacey Anthony Rapp alleged the actor
inappropriately touched him at a party
when he was 14 which was the space he
had vigorously denied so let's get more
on this now with our correspondent
Shaman Freeman Powell and Shaman what
more can you tell us about this case
then well we know that the jury had
deliberated for around an hour in their
Court in Manhattan before finding that
Anthony rap had not been able to prove
that Kevin Spacey had made these
unwanted sexual advances now rap who is
now 50 had accused Spacey of abusing him
when he was 14 years old and Spacey was
26 and Rapid being seeking around 40
million dollars in Damages in this of a
case before it was dismissed now we know
that this was one of the many cases that
came off the back of the metoo movement
which forced the entertainment industry
to address allegations of sexual abuse
and harassment and Kevin Spacey was one
of the many Hollywood actors to face
allegations and as a result Spacey's
reputation as an Oscar award-winning
actor had been tarnished he was sacked
from the hugely successful Netflix
series House of Cards and was even
forced to pay around 31 million dollars
in Damages to producers because of costs
that they would have occurred after
firing him now space he had
categorically denied the allegations and
after the lawsuit was dismissed was
reported to have hugged his lawyers
before leaving the courtroom but it
isn't the last time he's likely to see
the inside of a courtroom because he is
separately facing around five
allegations of sexual assault here in
the UK which he has pleaded not guilty
to and that trial is due to begin in
June next year
Shimon thanks very much indeed
well also making the news this morning a
former U.S spy has pleaded guilty to
causing the death by careless driving of
Harry Dunn following a three-year
campaign for Justice by the teenager's
family the 19 year old died in 2019
after being knocked off his motorbike by
Anne sekulis outside a U.S base in
northamptonshire she's been directed to
attend the sentencing hearing next month
the Biden Administration has accused
Iran of deploying troops in
russian-occupied Crimea to help launch
drone attacks on Ukraine the UK has
announced sanctions on Iranian
businesses and individuals responsible
for supplying the drones
former Liverpool Captain Stephen Gerrard
has been sacked as manager of Premier
League club Aston Villa he's been in
charge less than a year and leaves the
club at one place above the relegation
Zone
now there have been plenty of uneasy
moments for conservative supporters over
the past couple of weeks well here's
another one the latest polls
well this shows Skye's poll of polls of
voting intentions and you can see that
it crossed from a conservative lead
that's the blue line to a labor One the
red line during the party Gate scandal
but during Liz truss's leadership that
lead has widened to some 27 points
well joining me now is the head of
political and social research at opinion
Adam Drummond very good morning to you
Adam drummer thanks so much for talking
to us so the polar polls suggesting how
the Gap is widening between labor and
the conservatives at the moment so all
the more pressure on the Tories to pick
a leader that might reverse that
trajectory
exactly and it's always in quite a
difficult situation because boys
Johnson's approval waiting when he left
office in July was about 20 so only
about four points higher than Liz trust
is after all of the sort of Carnage in
the markets after the mini budget so the
the difficulty they've got is that
they're two most well-known figures the
boys Johnson and Richie sunac neither of
whom beats kirst armor in a head-to-head
um both of whom have got a significant
amount of baggage in the eyes of Voters
the only question really is whether one
of them appeals more to swing voters and
people who might be attempted to vote
labor and whether one of whether the
other one perhaps shows up the base a
little bit more and is more popular
among conservative voters
are there any other candidates that
would be care starmer
it's hard to tell at the moment uh
because one of the most unreliable
questions in political polling is how
would you vote if this person was the
leader or if this person was prime
minister because changing the party
leader is such a big event and it
affects all of the news coverage of a
party and and the the new cycle and
everything like that um so it's really
really difficult to tell
um all we can tell at the moment as far
as numbers go are that lots of the more
well-established candidates in the eyes
of Voters so people have been in the
cabinet for a while like Joey hunt or uh
privacy Michael Gove generally they do
even worse than the what we'll say sort
of the top couple of candidates
um the unknown one is is Penny mordant
although again the the issue there is
that whilst you may be um popular among
several of MPS she came third in the
leadership contest in the summer
um she is not widely known in the public
and she is untested in terms of holding
a major sort of domestic policy brief
and they're unlikely to be any big
surprises aren't there there's a high
bar for the number of conservative MPS
that have to back each candidate each
one has to have a hundred backers to
progress to what could be the next round
it could secure them the leadership
there and then
exactly I think the real question is
whether or not enough conservative MPS
have swallowed the the doubts that they
had about Boris Johnson in the summer
enough to put him through to a final
round I think based on the the
information we have at the moment uh
well based on on all the results that we
had uh before the contest in the summer
came down to the final two when every
poll showed which is unac losing to
either Liz truss or Penny mordant or
whoever else he was up against
um that gives us some idea of of how he
might do against Penny Warden what we
don't really know how well he'd do
against uh Boris Johnson and whether or
not enough conservative MPS would
um decide to go back on the various
reasons they gave for resigning from
boys Johnson's government and actually
put him through to the membership
and of course these candidates
popularity with the public may be very
different to their popularity within the
conservative party
that's exactly right and and boys
Johnson especially is one where you see
this uh being the case really so like I
said he left office with a 20 approval
rating
um most uh most voters who aren't uh
sort of currently conservative voters
have quite a negative opinion of him I
think what would most likely be the case
is if they went with boys Johnson he
might show up the base a little bit and
and
um you know not exactly drag the
conservatives to an election winning
position perhaps but but but sort of
contain the loss perhaps
um whereas if they choose somebody else
who might have more of a chance of
appealing to swing voters maybe there
was more upside there but potentially
there's also more downside
out of German fascinating to get your
taken at all um it'll be a very
interesting week ahead thanks very much
indeed
so let's get more reaction now to the
events here in Downing Street in the
last 24 hours joining me now is the
shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves a very
good morning to you Rachel Reeves thanks
so much for good morning good morning
what do you make of the resignation of
the Prime Minister do you welcome Liz
trust standing there
the longer the conservatives are in
power the less fit they are for
government to govern they can't just
pass around being prime minister and
being Chancellor like it's there's some
sort of game of past the parcel they've
done huge damage now to our economy to
our Global standing in the world and
it's time for a general election to
choose a government who can provide the
stability and the leadership that the
country desperately needs
well yes he wants a general election but
it's not going to happen is it I mean
that's in the gift of the Prime Minister
and anyone who takes over from Liz truss
isn't going to call one
well look I know that there are a lot of
decent conservative MPS so we're also
incredibly worried about the state of
the country the volatility and financial
markets the damage that that is all
doing to the finances of families and
pensioners right across the country and
I would urge them to do the right thing
and get the general election that we
need because I'm afraid at just a
changing the person at the top changing
the person at number 10 and number 11 is
not going to undo all of the damage that
the conservatives have done not just in
the last 45 days but frankly in the last
12 years where we've got economic growth
on the floor interest rates and
inflation are extraordinary levels and
this is a crisis clearly made in Downing
Street but it is increasingly working
people and some of the most vulnerable
in society who are paying the price for
that
so what will you do to try to secure a
general election will you push for a
confidence vote in the new prime
minister
well we're looking at all different uh
opportunities but in the end as as you
suggested earlier Anna we would have to
work with conservative MPS to be able to
do that because uh despite everything
they do have a majority in the House of
Commons but I know that there are a lot
of conservative MPS who share the
worries of their constituents that
another conservative prime minister and
Chancellor aren't going to be able to
sort out this mess the government has no
mandate from the British people for what
they're doing at the moment and no
mandate for a new prime minister and a
new Chancellor and that is why it is so
important to restore the stability that
we need in our country our ability to
pay our way in the world to get a grip
of the inflation and the interest rate
pressures that are out there at the
moment to secure family finances that we
cannot carry on like this and the only
way to resolve the big challenges that
we have is to have a government with a
mandate to provide the stability and the
leadership that people are crying out
for right now and are not going to get
under the conservatives
well if you're relying on Tory MPS it's
very unlikely you'll manage to secure
that general election and some might say
that two years will give the labor party
a chance to really familiarize the
public with what they what they stand
for what their policies are or are you
worried that you'll lose popularity over
the next two years before a general
election
my biggest concern right now Anna is
what is happening in the country
um people who are coming off fixed rate
mortgage deals 1.8 million of them by
the end of next year are looking to pay
an extra 580 pounds a month on average
well yes in higher mortgage payments
alone so that is why I'm saying that we
need a general uh election
um you know as long as it takes labor
will continue to put the case to people
but the sooner that we can have an
election the sooner that the country can
get the stability and Leadership yes
well sorry to to interrupt you but
you're right we are in the middle of a
cost of living crisis and some people
will say that's exactly why we don't
need the uncertainty of a general
election campaign
well you know I would just say that the
volatility that we've seen in the
financial markets has put increased
pressure on government borrowing but
it's also put increased borrowing costs
on families and businesses and and
everybody else I've been in Cardiff for
the last um uh 24 hours talking
particularly to small businesses here
about their fears for the future but
with people at not having the money to
uh to go to the shops uh the increased
energy costs that businesses are facing
people are worried sick about the future
worried sick about the cost of living
and they fear that just a new
combination of conservative prime
minister and Chancellor you know the
third conservative prime minister in a
year we're already on the fourth
conservative Chancellor in just four
months this is unprecedented and the
Damage every single day that the
conservatives are doing both to family
finances but also to our Global standing
in the world it is in incredibly
depressing and is taking a toll on
people's lives and people's livelihoods
the conservatives can't just swap around
who's in charge and they can't treat
number 10 and number 11 Downing Street
like it's some sort of short stay Airbnb
it's far too important for that and we
need a government with a mandate a
mandate from the British people to make
some of the difficult decisions that are
needed but to provide the leadership the
certainty and the stability that our
country needs well yes you talk about
difficult decisions I mean realistically
labor would have to spend the next two
years raising taxes and cutting spending
as well wouldn't they
well the reason we are talking about
these difficult decisions is because of
the damage that the conservatives have
done a month ago nobody was
contemplating the need for spending uh
reductions that is uh only on the agenda
now because of the spike in borrowing
costs brought about by the incredibly
irresponsible decisions of the
conservative party
um over the last few weeks but also so
that the labor would have to deliver
over the last 12.
sorry Rachel well we've already do
accept then that labor would have to go
ahead with spending cuts and tax Rises
well the first thing that I would say to
that is nobody knows because we do not
have an independent forecast from the
office for Budget responsibility and
we're in the extraordinary situation of
going into a conservative leadership
contest the second this year and also
going into potential uh fiscal statement
from the latest Chancellor in just over
a week's time with nobody knowing the
true scale of the damage that has been
done to our public finances that's why
in the House of Commons two days ago
labor called for the government to
publish the latest forecasts for the
office for Budget responsibility we know
that the government have had those
forecasts since uh Liz trust became a
prime minister uh 45 or 46 days ago we
deserve to see those so that we can
understand the true state of the public
finances because at the moment and
nobody knows there's full extent of the
damage and so it's very difficult to put
forward fully funded and fully costed
plans when we do not know the damage
that has been done
any thoughts on which candidate you'd
like to win and be next prime minister
I want Kia stama to be the next prime
minister because he's the only person
who can provide the stability that the
country needs you know the conservatives
can carry on with their past the parcel
game but the country deserves an awful
lot better than that we deserve a
general election and the chance for the
people to choose who the government is
not what I meant but I I guess that was
always the way you would answer the
question there Rachel Ruiz thanks very
much indeed for your time this morning
thank you Anna
so after 44 chaotic days as prime
minister Liz truss has stepped down but
in what state has she left the
conservative party
well her Premiership was dramatic and
ultimately catastrophic so let's take a
little look back it was former
Chancellor quasiquartang's radical mini
budget unveiled less than three weeks
after her appointment the plunge list
trusses leadership into chaos his
announcement of 45 billion pounds in
unfunded tax cuts sparked Market turmoil
and a political backlash then 10 days
later came the first U-turn Mr kwate
announcing the government would be
abandoning the cut to the top rate of
income tax
a week ago he was sacked by the Prime
Minister and replaced with Jeremy Hunt
on Monday the new Chancellor reversed
almost all of the tax measures in the
mini budget and scaled back the energy
price guarantee
then on Tuesday a new poll revealed that
mistrust's popularity rating had slumped
to the lowest ever of any UK political
leader
another blow on Wednesday when swella
bravaman quitter's Home Secretary for
breaching government security rules and
also hit out at the PM expressing
concern about the government's Direction
by yesterday it was all over following
meetings with senior Tories Liz truss
resigned
well Bromwich Maddox is the former
director at The Institute of government
and she joins me now good morning to you
Bronwyn Maddox what are your thoughts on
this did the conservative party and the
Prime Minister make the right call was
this trust right to stand down
yes I don't think there was any
alternative at all she'd lost all her
policies policies she'd lost some of her
main people already and um there was
just no credibility left so that was
absolutely the right decision
how damaged you think the Tory party and
the country has been by this episode
the country has been rocked in its sense
of confidence and people have been left
with slightly higher interest rates than
uh that would have happened um if Liz
trusted to have a smoother Premiership
that yes as she was saying there are
outside pressures that are pushing up
interest rates and mortgage rates but
people have been left with higher rates
because of this turmoil there is a sort
of lingering effect of that even though
her policies have been uh reversed
um the party itself has been enormously
damaged it has shown that it can't pick
a good leader and that it can't unite
behind one so it's got one more chance
can it do that really next week can uh
Tory MPS come behind one figure and try
and Salvage the next two years and uh
and um uh put together us later policies
that actually have some credibility
and what do you make of the mechanism
that's been laid out to choose that next
leader with that big
head of them they've set a pretty high
bar 100 MPS have to back each candidate
for them to have a chance of going
forward what do you think that tells us
about the kind of people who might go
through
it tells us that it may be Rishi sunak
and Penny mordant and hard to see
uh all the talk about Boris Johnson
really coming to anything I think
um he might want to be the kind of
vindication of people talking about him
again as a possible leader but I I'd be
surprised if he actually wanted it with
a real possibility that he goes on to
lose the next general election so I
think it's really down to those two I
and um the party must be hoping or quite
a few people in it that it's going to be
just one that it could be settled very
very quickly within days certainly
Graham Brady head of the head of the
committee that is running this process
has said possibly within a week they'll
have a new leader what they don't want
to do is uh to have to go out to members
again that was the the round of the
contest that put Liz truss uh in in the
front and led to all kinds of
controversy about it being even less
representative than you could argue that
MPS are
what yes Instagram Brady says that we'll
get a result by next week this Friday
next week but that would only give the
new prime minister a matter of days to
get their head around what Jeremy Hunt
has has planned on Monday the 31st with
his fiscal statement that's a huge task
isn't it
yes it is you'd have to assume it was
someone who um the whole thing will be
smoother if it's someone who agrees with
what Jeremy Hunt has already indicated
um which is a you know a very uh
conservative in the classic way budget
looking at explaining where the money is
coming from and uh you know a mixture of
um of some tax Rises probably and some
spending cuts but you know what he's
laid out is essentially the policies
that Rishi sunak was arguing for in the
leadership campaign so it would clearly
be easiest if that um if it all went
that way
um Penny mordant doesn't have that kind
of financial reputation but does have a
presence and a following in the party
um I find it hard to think that that one
would bring as much stability to the
general picture but I'll have to see
what the MPS pick it is and this is a
constitutional point it is down to the
MPS and uh they have one more go in my
view
well yes I'm presumably
yeah sorry finish your point right being
before before
um if they can't pick a single candidate
now then I think it does go to a general
election
um and very quickly any new leader will
want to have their own cabinet a
reshuffle then presumably means a
certain amount of paralysis once again
at a time when the country is going
through a huge cost of living crisis
yes I know that that that's exactly
right and the cost of living crisis
isn't going to go away and that is the
main thing for any uh leader to tackle
as well as what's happened to Britain
standing in the world which has been
really damaged by this
problematic it's really interesting to
get your take thanks very much indeed
so what impact will the chaos at
Westminster have on the so-called red
wall seats in the north of England seats
taken by the conservatives in the last
general election with the promise of
regeneration and leveling up well Fraser
Maude is in Wakefield which labor won
back from the Tories in a by-election in
June so you no doubt have been talking
to a lot of people there Fraser what are
they saying to you
well pretty quiet here at the moment I
have to say we're in the create Cafe it
doesn't open for another hour or so but
I can have a chat with the owner sure
man so he's been running the place here
for 10 years or so
as bad as it gets I guess at the moment
is it it is yeah it's um the hardest
period we've had since we since we
started uh the the energy crisis the um
the the shambolic government it's uh it
needs a change so this trust is gone
we're going to get another new prime
minister within the next week or so any
idea who you want it to be well we've
got a choice we've had to go on number
five of the of the list or we go back to
Boris what choice do we have we need we
need an election don't we simple so you
think that that's the most the most
sensible thing a general election yeah
yeah I don't think this government can
carry on
well Mr certainly can't she's decided
that that she won't Richie sunac Boris
Johnson Penny Morton we've we've got a
couple of names being been banded around
at the moment no one for deaf in it do
you think it's a step back going back to
Boris or do you think we need to look
for look for uh fresh Talent well it's a
choice isn't it like like I said we're
already number five on the list so you
know going back to Boris Boris did all
right there was a couple of
indiscretions but were they that bad
were they that bad did he you know send
the send the pound to a plumber into an
all-time low no the poor guy dealt with
a global pandemic a war
um and God knows what else but you know
he dealt with a lot of things in his
time and he dealt with them well until
the end and then there was a couple of
indiscretions I mean we hear about this
the red wall wakefield's gone back to
red again after people lending the
conservatives their their vote what do
you think would happen at a general
election red wall back in uh back in
business again I I would think so
um personally I think there's 38 the
population that haven't voted in the
last election and we could have a real
shock decision if everyone that hasn't
voted previously but you know we could
have one of the outlying parties coming
to boss so what needs to happen when
someone new does come in next week what
do you want them to do what can they do
to help out businesses like yours where
your costs are spiraling I'm not sure
I'm not an economist
um but I think we need to we need to
start having windfall taxes on energy
companies
um we need to get the energy crisis
under control
um it that's not going to go away
um but the government won't tax the
energy companies because they're all in
bed together in big business so that's
that's obviously the reason that we're
not taxing them and we'll just tax the
little person on the street okay Sean
look thanks ever so much for talking to
us and are you going to start getting
busy at any time now that you get back
in the kitchen there so uh that's a word
from here in Wakefield Sean definitely
thinks that a general election is the
only way forward we need some stability
we need some economic certainty which
has been pretty scarce for the past few
months
indeed Fraser thanks very much indeed
for that
well let's get another view now joining
me is the former press secretary Deborah
Johnson and current managing director of
public affairs at Adelman UK will Walden
good morning to you will award nice to
talk to you first of all hello did she
have to go
yeah she absolutely did I mean
essentially none of her policies were
left
um her her obsession with small state
Britain uh you know tanked the economy
essentially and there was no way back
and once she had replaced her Chancellor
with Jeremy Hunt and he ditched her all
her policies there was only one way and
that was out the door I mean I think
there probably will be very little
Sympathy For Liz truss among the public
this morning polls suggested just two
percent think she did a good job but
from a personal point of view it's an
absolute tragedy and it's a humiliation
uh you know and she will have to live
with the fact now that her place in
history is the shortest serving prime
minister she'll essentially be the
answer to a pub quiz question and that
must be terrible for her personally but
you know the country couldn't carry on
as it is and we needed a change the
problem is that I don't think there's
any clarity about what that change will
look like
well yes and what's your take given that
you work closely with Boris Johnson do
you think he will try to run again
you know everyone's saying oh um you
know Johnson's in the frame he's he's
flying back I've spoken to someone
that's spoken to him and he is on the
way back and clearly he's taking
soundings but the thing about Boris is
that he absolutely hates to lose and I
suspect that if he doesn't think he can
get to the hundred or more importantly
he can he can come second in this in the
in the first boat because I think you
know Richie sunac is is clearly the
front runner then he won't run but if he
does think he can then I'm sure he will
because you know in his mind he's done
nothing wrong he's been unfairly
defenestrated whether you think that's
true or not it doesn't matter to Boris
and it's not a case of the national
interest it's a case of boris's Interest
so if he thinks that he has a chance of
winning with the members vote next week
you know then he'll run I think the
problem with that is that you know the
Tory party doesn't have a Unity
candidate and they seem to have those
that are backing him already seem to
have forgotten very quickly what's
happened you know Boris and his best had
an elastic relationship with the truth
but if you had everything that happened
Patterson and parties and Pinscher and
the way he governed and the fact that
you know before he left there were two
horrific by-election defeats in a way
the the the the beholding of Liz Trust
of the country was Boris Johnson's
responsibility and I think you know we
are we are all guilty of collective
Amnesia if we forget that six weeks ago
70 of the country consistently wanted
him out including a majority of Tory
voters and there's no evidence that
they've changed their mind there's also
no evidence that Boris has changed his
mind in terms of how he'll behave or how
he'll govern uh I think the problem for
the Tory party at the moment is that
there isn't necessarily A Unity
candidate you know I was on another
broadcaster earlier Anna and I suggested
that there was some unanimity amongst
perhaps a small majority of Tory
Ventures that Rishi sunak you know was
the front runner and could be a Unity
candidate and a very senior member of
the government texted me and said that
that's rubbish you know he's almost as
unpopular among many as as Boris Johnson
so there is no easy choice I think if
there was a Unity candidate it would be
somebody like the defense secretary Ben
Wallace I think there's two problems
there that I I get the sense that Ben
Wallace won't run uh and the other thing
is that the country doesn't know what a
Ben Wallace platform would look like so
I think it's a horrific mess and I think
they've got a week to get it right and
I'm not sure they're necessarily going
to
and is there actually such a thing as a
Unity candidate when you've got a party
that's so divided
yeah and I think that's the problem is
that you know are they thinking in the
best interest of the conservative party
or the best interest of the of the
country and the problem is that the
conservative party is now so Riven not
just with factions but just with a sense
of identity what does it actually stand
for and the truth is the idea that we're
suddenly going to find that out in only
a week from somebody I think is
is laughable so I I think that you know
there is clearly a sense among the the
sort of governing or managing hierarchy
in the conservative party talking to
some of them that that what they really
need is for you know this contest to
have a clear front runner and then
whoever comes second assuming it isn't
Boris Johnson
um it's a fold in behind that person I
think the trouble is that's a that's a
huge ask and we don't know you know who
that person who might come second
whether they would want to fold in you
know anyone that comes second in this
contest presumably thinks they have a
chance of winning why would they do that
and that's partly a problem with the
system of electing the next leader it's
also part here part a problem with the
fact that the Tory party has lost its
identity and that's why I think that
unfortunately the likely outcome is that
whoever they choose
um you know that Unity will dissipate
fairly quickly and I suspect we'll end
up with a general election in pretty
short order
well will wasn't always fascinating to
get your take thanks very much indeed
for your time this morning we really do
appreciate it thanks
[Music]